la malaisie renvoi 150 conteneurs de
déchets plastiques illégaux vers leur
pays d'origine
quarante trois proviennent de la france
concernait également royaume uni etats
unis canada et japon
cette action fait suite à la décision de
kuala lumpur de ne pas devenir je cite
la décharge des pays développés florian
lambert la malaisie capitale mondiale du
déchet 150 conteneurs de déchets
plastiques illégaux ont été renvoyés de
malaisie vers leur pays d'origine
43 concerne la france les autorités de
ce pays d'asie du sud est ont affirmé
qu'elles ne voulaient pas que leur
territoire devienne une décharge pour
les pays développés
mais la ministre malaisienne de
l'environnement liés aux been souhaite
collaborer avec les pays concernés pour
régler ce conflit notamment les états
unis à ce jour le gouvernement de la
malaisie a renvoyé 150 conteneurs de
plastique des déchets plastiques
illégaux contenant quelque 3700 37
tonnes grâce à notre inspection dans les
paréos données du département royal des
douanes malaisienne la plupart des
conteneurs sont exportés des pays
développés notamment la france le
royaume-uni les etats-unis et le canada
l'espagne et le japon ce celui qui doit
être renvoyée vient des états unis
nous en avons encore 60 sur 110 qui
viennent des états unis
nous continuerons donc à travailler avec
le gouvernement américain les organismes
locaux compétents aux états unis pour
nous assurer que nous les renverrons le
marché mondial du recyclage a connu un
bouleversement majeur depuis la décision
en 2018 de la chine de cesser
l'importation de déchets plastiques
de nombreuses entreprises chinoises de
recyclage ont été délocalisée en
malaisie entraînant un afflux de déchets
souvent est légal
plusieurs pays d'asie du sud-est ont
pratiqué la même politique ces derniers
mois l'indonésie a également expédié
plusieurs centaines de conteneurs vers
leur pays d'origine
en juin dernier le canada avait rapatrié
plusieurs tonnes de déchets entreposés
aux philippines durant plusieurs années
un contentieux qui avait provoqué une
longue crise diplomatique entre les deux
pays